[Music]
it's communication
is it true that this guy was really up
to play Ross back in the day no that's a
very big possibility were you really up
to play Ross were you no
no so there's your answer oh no I'm very
confused you said an interview I guess
that Schwimmer was nicer and taller I
thought well he he is but
but uh I didn't I know that wasn't real
I was just joking
[Music]
hearing you guys on Drew Barrymore
explore the idea of maybe doing a
Three's Company
get that to go like the ball rolling
into the sweatshirt and mask I don't
know if that's the one that would be
funny I'm sure if someone wrote a great
script depends on
what happened and if they enjoyed
themselves and had a good time and
Netflix will hopefully just say yep in
Murder Mystery 2 streaming Friday on
Netflix the big crime goes down at a
wedding but in real life where does
Jennifer Aniston hang out at a party
usually close to an exit
where do we find Jody Turner Smith at
the park down school can Joshua hold
step with you you know what Josh cannot
dance but I love that he I love that he
wants to express himself through
movement anyway Josh I love you it's not
with me how about him taking over
Michael Douglas's role in Fatal
Attraction I can't wait to see you're
talking about raising a biracial
daughter and saying that like the
universe was teaching you lessons well I
mean that's honestly the way that this
is like pushing me challenging me making
me sit with all the conversations I've
ever had I love that and I love it I
love it so much
foreign